where the packages what's this
you should go out of the car all of you
now no one's getting out of the car now
drive seat belts now well first of all I
love this story the story is so
different than the unfriend eyes films
and I love the character and and I was
like wow I'm gonna be playing that
really really tough woman and she's got
a real place in in the story so I was
really excited to be a part of it I
tried to bring some emotion to the role
I tried to base everything from an
emotional point of view where there was
the fight sequences or the the dialogue
sequence if I tried to make him as human
as possible
your clients tone for me that's not my
problem it is now you're gonna need more
men
you just want to get revenge so I think
it's more about her getting the power
back that's been taking away from her a
long time ago perhaps we work together
again in the future that's no kind of
awesome I think it's a mind game there's
yours
there's speedboats this fast cars cool
girls cool guys there's a hell of a lot
of feast your eyes on the incredible I'm
XP
I mean when it's an action film you know
you have to see the Knights it's a right
so it makes it even more provide when
you can see it in IMAX